Lindsey is with us in Oklahoma City hi
Lindsey how are you hey good thanks for
taking my call Dave sure what's up um
well my husband and I had bought two new
cards before we started listening to you
and so I'm looking to training the man
but we've got about $20,000 and negative
equity on both of them and our budgets
pretty tight right now what's having
them so that's why I was trying to get
rid of them but why would I just don't
know what to do okay
what is your household income about
seventy thousand and what do you owe on
the car number one about thirty five
thousand good horn on one car yeah
they're both we do about 35,000 on both
of them each so you have $70,000 in car
debt yes
good god and ten thousand dollars
negative equity on each one about $15
yeah and and who do you owe the money to
on the cars um one of them is tinker and
the other one is stay farming okay um it
is possible not with tinker but with
State Farm I don't know you have to
check with them um basically these come
caught these little car loans are what
we would call partially secured meaning
you you the collateral does not cover
the loan do you see what I'm saying yeah
so it's kind of like State Farm has a
$25,000 car loan and a $10,000 unsecured
loan it's kind of what it's like you see
what I'm saying
yeah because they're not covered for at
least ten of it and so what I would do
is talk to them about letting you sell
the car giving them a hundred percent of
the proceeds from the sale of the car
and then signing a note for the
difference and on that one or the and or
the other one you may have to just go to
your credit union try to borrow the
difference the ten thousand dollars and
get a buyer to buy the car and you got
to cover the difference in order to get
the title from
tinker or from State Farm in order to
give it to them you've got to get out of
these cars both of them are insanity I
don't even know how you got these dadgum
loans I mean the finance manager must
have been smoking crack
who gives people $70,000 where the car
loans make $70,000
that's a dumbest butt thing I've ever
heard on the planet it's unbelievable
that you were even able to pull this
stupidity off at this level so you
really have no excuses get you a $500
car and get this crap out of your life
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
Oh